yo
appreciate you for pulling up appreciate
your time so what's the timeline on the
album
so you say you know we just talked about
three different new albums
yeah man hopefully uh giovanni's way be
out here by like
august but don't hold me today so
that'll be the first thing we're waiting
for
yeah okay then uh then doug boyce cash
out and i got
a project with zaytov and i'm working on
two
oh [ __ ] and zaytoven coming with a whole
other bag on this [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] it sounds different so you got
four projects on the way i probably got
more than that for real
any other collab projects with any other
artists like full collab projects
not with no artists i got something with
different producers though
yeah me and hallelujah of course me and
hello and uh
the olympics okay yeah of course yeah my
man's knoxville
was is there an uh you know you and pz
linked up for a project is there another
artist in detroit that that you would
love to do just a
just a full-on collab album with
i mean i'm open to anything for real but
me and peas are actually talking about
doing another project too
you know who's gonna follow i think
they've been just killing [ __ ] ever
since they they they
really went straight independent and
they were independent before but uh i
swear vezo been on his [ __ ] like oh yeah
yeah
he stayed matching on the game he's been
killing it yeah i know he was on that
motown situation and
you know they kind of stalled them out a
little but like
my deal situation he broke free and he's
just better off independent straight gas
that's how detroit artists work though
like we better independent with our own
freedom there it is man
look payroll giovanni appreciate you for
pulling up four or five or seven albums
coming soon
yeah about five six of them there it is
movies all that
hopefully we hear this yg gz yeah we're
gonna talk
into existence man the next time i see
the full album there it is
perfect for the show appreciate you man